he is Chris Webber how are you C Webb
Hey same here our poll question is who's
the MVP right now and I get the are our
choices our Chris our choices our James
Harden LeBron James Anthony Davis or the
field who would you take I would take
Harden and you know it's funny I'm not
gonna lie to you I'm I'm being a little
hypocritical in the fact that I'm as a
player as a player I used to hate it
when people in the media rooted for a
guy I thought it was very unprofessional
you know even if the story was as crazy
as say Stefan when he when they and
stuff when they won 73 games he wanted
unanimously but I'm I won't say that I'm
rooting but I'll say this I don't think
an MVP we've ever had an MVP come in
second three years in a row with the
type of basketball we've seen whether
it's the 73 win team with gold and stay
whether it was Westbrook avenues
averaging a triple-double I mean
historic things have had to happen for
Harden not to win actually you know the
players voted him as the MVP the first
time step one so you know I'm not
rooting for him but after all those
years it's great to see him be this
consistent and still be kind of the
forerunners but LeBron is you've seen
he's the MVP every year as well yeah I
mean it's gonna be tough but maybe it's
just as simple as you just pointed out
he's come close and he's also clearly
the most dynamic player on the team with
the most wins and perhaps the top seed
in the West even with cp3 on there what
is the difference between Harden season
last year and this year best you can
tell Chris truthfully statistically
nothing the only difference is he has
Chris Paul who helps with leadership at
the end and helps you know do some
things there at the end
I farted game maybe he's learned a
little bit of leadership maybe better in
the fourth quarter but really as
problems happen in the playoff so we
won't see until then but I mean let's
just think about this he broke the
franchise record for points with 60
points
for Houston but that wasn't enough in
that same game he's the first player
ever prog besides will because they just
didn't take the stats oh but the first
guy ever we took the stats with that has
60 in a triple-double in NBA history and
I just it's just amazing I mean by far
he and Durant to me are the best
offensive players got to put curry up
there in this league and you know he has
highlights you know it's just is he's
just really fun to watch I think he
feels all the boxes as far as the MVP
entertaining fun team winning and has a
story and all that good stuff so how is
Houston built to beat Golden State let's
get right down to brass tacks here you
know you know people kind of laughed at
me I think all-star when when someone
asks me could Houston be going to state
I wouldn't bet my money on it but um I
do think Houston can be going to state I
think they're built for a team like that
what do I mean they're all like sighs so
that means now that they could now now
they can switch like when we played it
in Sacramento we loved it if you got
into a running game with this it made it
look like maybe you are playing because
you've scored four more points again but
you took seven more shots a game and we
wanted you to get into that running game
with us and so most times Golden State
has won the game even before it started
because most teams don't even know how
to play that pace or they don't have the
guys with the skillset well Houston does
and they have a guy that can handle the
mid-range and Chris Paul
they have defenders whether there's a
reserve whether it's Gordon whether it's
any of these guys they can all switch
and you know they can play fast and and
capella can switch out he can dominate
inside by just doing the pick-and-roll
and then you have heart and soul yeah
yeah I think that uh did they stay
focused they can but I also think that
we're going to see a crazy upset in the
playoffs because everybody's looking
forward to the next round there's some
good teams on the west and I think that
you know you never know what's going to
happen in that second round so identify
one for me Portland I mean no one talks
about Damian Lillard nobody nobody
nobody and because he doesn't even have
any buddies on his team you know he's
kind of cursed with that West Coast
kurtz meaning that you know
come on at 10 o'clock 10:30 and if you
don't have a great team nobody's
watching you know I think them at Denver
you know gets in you never know but I
just you know you never know where San
Antonio you know all this you know maybe
so-called fake drama going on over there
just because it's the first time we've
heard it's been a problem in San Antonio
I don't know if it is a problem and what
if the heart of Kauai comes back at the
right time so you just never know but
one thing I like I hope that we never go
to a 1 through 16 seating in the NBA
because it's all cyclical is it's all
but and if you look at right now the
playoffs are started there's teams the
other night Tuesday that were in 4th
place but if they lost they'd be in 9th
place that night so I love the fact that
the playoffs have already started in
conference games himself well Chris
whoever here on the Rich Eisen show
you're you're running counter to what
I'm hearing on this show with guests of
no I mean will bond being won a couple
others who were closely associated with
these a Calvin Murphy the other day said
it that they wished it would be 1
through 16 seed right now because that
would mean Houston versus Golden State
would be the finals you're the first to
come out here to say you just you
wouldn't want that no no and you know I
understand everybody has the right you
know it's out there thing and I've
talked to guys to weathers are they or
Thomas or other you know Hall of Famers
as well that agree just think about this
so now we're going to have the first
round be Toronto again to the Clippers
you know what type of travel nightmare
that will cost so now it's going to be
unfair to that so now again in Chicago
and Milwaukee doesn't matter you talk
about tanking the season so now why does
that rivalry what what rivalries matter
you know and then where do you have
context of history all to have a 1
through 16 seeding so maybe we'll have
Houston well let me tell you this Golden
State's not going to have all of their
players in three years so if we're
making rules for three years from now go
to States not going to have draymond
Green curry the great Durant they all
can't Thompson they can't it just can't
happen with the way that the the way
that the cap is set up so if we're doing
that and then we did some terrible games
and there's Memphis against
Toronto at the end and it should have
been that anyway I just I mean that's
just one you don't have to change I mean
you don't have to change everything
I mean why I mean but we have guys going
into the seeding of the playoffs playing
hard in every game matters so what does
it matter one through sixteen you know I
don't get it you don't think the
Warriors will just look at each other
and say we got a good thing going here
let's all keep hometown discounting our
way to two championships you don't think
we're gonna stick together
it's impossible man I hate to ruin the
story for everybody I know you know but
there's so much so many stories in
basketball it's impossible for all for
them do you know if the luxury tax would
be and by the way they'll be four years
older you know so I don't really know I
really don't see that and there are
other good teams this is not just you
know the Bulls had you know what Jordan
won six okay like six years I mean you
know somebody else is gonna dominate one
day I hope some guys get better than she
was guys get older so I just wouldn't
make that rule it's like too many other
rules that we need to change before we
go seeding in the playoffs based on what
we have great games now going into the
playoffs that's all on a couple more
minutes left with Chris Webber here I
want to turn the page to college
basketball's cuz Steve Kerr did say that
he thinks that players who get droughts
don't get drafted should be able to
return to college basketball even if
they've signed with an agent where do
you stand on this whole one-and-done
situation that I think a lot of people
in college basketball even John Beilein
from Michigan was on yesterday Chris
saying that they're looking to the NBA
to fix this thing as opposed to the
n-c-double-a first of all what a job
he's done there with the boys and job he
has done right and congratulations you
have Big Ten champs I think there are a
lot of a lot of input that needs to be
in I don't think a four-person
five-person board can do it I think an
input from everyone where I would start
is that students need health care mental
health physical health there are
students that I know men and women that
are from the age of about 22 guys that I
went to
and females I went to school with that
are still affected by the injuries or
the mental scars of going through
certain situations so that that would be
one number to the fact that if you help
a university during the time now that
you should always be able to go back and
graduate
there are many athletes better and other
poor financial positions or would love
to go back and finish but the university
they went to maybe their time or to the
university to a coach then to rule their
service at the University so I think you
would have to think about that in no way
do I want anything to stop I love the
games and I'm excited about the the
games that are going to happen in the
stories I mean it's the last real time
of innocence when you think of a player
because we're going to watch teams that
one game one game winning in the
tournament is a championship it is how
you play the game it's not about whether
you win or lose for most teams that come
there it is about their parents finally
getting to see them on a certain level
or watch their kids on TV and be proud
that all their sacrifice and prayers
finally played awesome for that one
moment it is about seeing like a South
Carolina team's coach finally get it
just do when you know when I was
watching other players with watch we
knew it was just like for coaches that
would only get praised and the rest of
them wouldn't get their prey is like a
Huggins or someone else so for me I love
being part of it to celebrate the game
and celebrate the people to celebrate
the students I mean the band's Wichita
state's band there's no funky so it is
you know but we need to have an honest
conversation and for those that are just
you know sunshine rainbows and don't
want to address certain things you know
so I don't I I think that everyone
should be part of the conversation but I
think it's such a long conversation that
it's hard to have in one or two segments
because you're not only can you get
misinterpreted but I think that there
are different levels to everything so
paying students or or the fact of taking
some and putting it in house growing
donated at the student so you know it
certain things to talk about not on
the coaches should be adversely affected
I always hear we'll take it from the
coaches no I know I don't think you do
that because they do a great job I think
it's about addressing the system and I
think the quicker you do it I think
everyone just needed to learn the
quicker you address it you know I trust
this you know I think you know people
can you know move forward so I just hope
the best for the game and I'm excited
about NCAA tournament up it's coming up
6:00 p.m. Eastern Time selection sunday
and finally on TBS for the very first
time
Chris whoever see what I've always loved
having you on will chat down the line
okay sounds good always at real Chris
Weber the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience